One of  the craziest things about ISIS is how many people it recruits
around the world
By one count
over 20,000 people have come to Iraq and
Syria to fight their, most of them for ISIS
if that's correct it would be a historical
record for the number of people who
volunteered for this kind of conflict.
why would anyone give up their life
to join in brutal vicious militant group,
one that's fighting on all sides and in
the long run is facing a really long
shot of holding on to the territory it
controls.
It's a critically important question
because these foreign fighters
are major source of ISIS' strength. Expert: many other
people coming have not had a sense of purpose.
Have not had dignity and respect
or something to do; a life Project.
And now they have one.
one of the things that makes ISIS
unique relative to terrorist organizations
that came before it is the degree of
sophistication of their social media operation.
ISIS has invested a lot of effort in
developing a very slick
social media presentation including
sophisticated videos
with narratives and high production
values.
Expert: they're clearly focused on the glory of the battle and
what the state has accomplished.
Very inspirational
for these young man many of whom, not all,
but most of whom
have not had a sense of purpose in life
and have not had
any means to or earn a living to
get married to do the kind of things
that they feel would bring them into an
adult life And now here's an opportunity to
prove themselves as young men.
In February 2015 The Islamic State was able to shoot
down a Jordanian F-16
They captured the pilot and
paraded before some of the bodies that is bombing resulted in.
Some of the dead. Just demonstrating that
Jordanian aircraft have brought death to
civilians and of course the constant
imagery the charring.
And then they burn him.
This is about settling scores
and seeking justice. And so that
his terribly stimulating for these young
men to see that.
ISIS' video portray them as saviors as heroes as people
resisting evil and violent regimes that
oppress Muslim specifically Sunni Muslims.
That way, you motivate people who might
want to join ISIS to go
travel around the world and fight for
what they perceive as being justice.
That way ISIS, a violent,
terrible, brutal militant group ends up
being seen as the good guys.
This isn't a small problem.
ISIS has recruited tens of thousands of
people. This is made
their military empire their stronger and,
because these foreign fighters have so much conviction,
often more radical more dangerous for the
people that live there.
So these things are serious problems
and no one really knows how to solve them